hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
to hide the new climate data which
exposes the world's worst police and
shows emissions could be three times
higher than producers claim
China welcomes a compensation fund for
vulnerable Nations but says it's in no
rush to close its coal mines
plus the impassioned plea from Africa's
youth not to build new gas projects
children cannot eat coal children cannot
drink oil during colored breed guys
and as cop hosts Egypt pump more money
into green hydrogen we consider if it
could be the fuel of the future
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now one solution to measuring
climate change more accurately was
proposed today by the former U.S vice
president Al Gore now he was speaking at
the cop 27 climate Summit in Egypt about
a new Global Research Coalition he's
part of called a climate Trace which
aims to expose the world's worst
pollution hot spots so climate Trace
uses satellite imagery and AI to build
data on emissions from across the world
now their data suggests emissions from
oil and gas production are significantly
under reported and could be up to three
times higher than producers claim now
that's concerning because oil and gas
production Fields make up half of the 50
largest sources of greenhouse gases well
here was Mr Gore laying out the scale of
the problem and how climate Trace could
help we are causing the climate crisis
by spewing 162 million tons of man-made
global warming pollution into that thin
shell of atmosphere around our planet
every day as if it's an open sewer it is
not an open sewer it is a very thin
shell if you could drive an automobile
straight up in the air from the ground
you would get to the top of that blue
line in about five to seven minutes we
found last year shockingly that oil and
gas production emissions were about
double what they had reported to the
United Nations with new data on the
flaring and the methane leaks we we now
estimate that the actual emissions are
likely three times higher than what they
have reported this this is the
self-reported
CO2 equivalent emissions that includes
CO2 and methane this is what the actual
measurements show this is really a
shocking
well the new research tool was welcomed
by the UN Secretary General who said it
would leave nowhere to hide for those
Nations most guilty of polluting the
planet many significant sources of
emissions are not yet on our rather in
real time
and that is where
this initiative comes in you are making
it more difficult to greenwash
or to be more clear to cheat
climate change and energy correspondent
Hannah Thomas Peter joins me from cop27
in Egypt welcome Hannah so first of all
this system is yet to be adopted by any
government but from the data so far it
could be quite embarrassing for those
big polluters
yes and I think you know governments
National entities would say look it's no
surprise that oil and gas organizations
are Under reporting uh their emissions
but there's been a real focus on
greenwashing um at this cop this is one
initiative launched by Al Gore and
others to give governments a forensic
idea of who is polluting and where and
the thing that has driven most of the
concern actually is discovering more
about methane leaks and flaring methane
is a very powerful greenhouse gas much
more powerful than carbon dioxide
although it stays in the atmosphere for
a much shorter length of time time and
it is the opinion of America for example
that that represents an easy win in the
fight against the climate crisis that if
we can stop methane leaks and
unnecessary Emissions on that front
um then there will be a Leap Forward in
terms of tackling global warming
okay Hannah thank you we will have more
from Hannah shortly but China is the
world's biggest polluter but today it's
climate Envoy said the country will be
willing to pay into a loss and damage
fund to help compensate those most
affected by climate change now there's a
crucial caveat though China says it
won't close its Coal Power stations
until renewable alternatives are fully
in place to provide Power to its
population of 1.4 billion
well we are vigorously developing
renewable energy it is necessary to
solve the problem of intermittency of
renewable energy to ensure the stability
of the power grid energy and the
security of society so we must retain
coal at a certain stage you ask if
China's coal production increased we're
building some new Coal Fire plants but
they are the most efficient coal plants
in the world
okay let's go back to our climate change
and energy correspondent Hannah Thomas
Peter
um so Hannah what do you think this says
about China's commitments to decarbonize
well there are some real concerns about
China obviously there has been for a
long time it is the world's second
largest economy but the biggest polluter
responsible for some 30 of greenhouse
gas emissions and 85 percent of its
energy mix actually comes from fossil
fuels it's promised to get to Net Zero
by 2060. I think there is widespread
belief that it can do so but of course
that's 10 years later than at most of
the rest of similar sized economies
who've all gone for for 20 20 50 and the
other thing that's giving
um people worries particularly climate
diplomats behind the scenes is that ever
since house Speaker Nancy Pelosi visited
Taiwan the very
um you know hard one but quite fragile
cooperation between the US and China on
on the climate crisis has disintegrated
a bit and John Kerry has not really been
in full contact at least not publicly
with his Chinese counterpart all of that
being said it is believed you know
there's a kind of widespread opinion
that China although it it's a huge
polluter although it does huge damage in
terms of burning fossil fuels and it is
refusing to bring down its coal use
before 2026. it is well on its way to
becoming a renewable energy superpower
and it certainly has the capacity to get
that done okay Hannah thank you very
much good to hear from you
now on yesterday's program we touched on
the frustration being felt by some
African governments at being told not to
spend future Global investment on
funding new gas projects now the
International Energy agency has echoed
those calls and today the Ugandan
climate campaign and UNICEF Goodwill
Ambassador Vanessa nakante gave this
warning against new fossil fuel projects
on the continent
to those who have come to cop 27 with
the intention of promoting new fossil
fuels I say no we will not let you gas
Africa
the oil and gas they dig up will be
shipped straight back to countries in
the global North and the profits in the
pockets of the multinational oil and gas
companies children cannot eat coal
children cannot drink oil children
cannot breathe gas
and that message was echoed by
protesters who demonstrated outside the
conference center in charmel Shake today
three dozen climate activists held a
small protest calling for accelerating
the transition to renewable energy and
it was a rare showing of activism in
Egypt which has been criticized for
cracking down on protests and detaining
demonstrators
now one alternative source of energy
being explored and invested in by cop
hosts is green hydrogen together with
Norway they've just launched at the
first phase of a project to establish a
major green hydrogen plant on the Red
Sea now it's all parts of a wider
hydrogen strategy to produce green
hydrogen at the cheapest price worldwide
well investments in hydrogen projects in
Egypt has now passed a hundred billion
dollars and that brings its production
capacity at a three point million tons
seconds in the world only to Australia
which leads the table by some way well
how much faith is there in green
hydrogen globally and will it pay off
well joining me now uh is rice says
energy head of hydrogen research mikoi
Lee thank you very much for joining us
so do you think there's a future then in
green hydrogen
definitely uh first of all thank you
very much for having me on your show uh
and well I think that definitely there
is a future for green hydrogen in the
world of energy transition and as well
as decarbonization
how do you think it will be used if it's
made on this mask
so there's actually a lot of ways that
hydrogen can be used is actually being
used around the world at the moment and
one of the key use if we look into the
future is of course to make nitrogen
based higher fertilizers to support our
food industry other uses uh including
you know fuel for transportation
feedstock for steel production as well
as for our generation as well so there's
a lot of use that you can make out of
green hydrogen and it's often being
tooted it's one of the key pillars of
the energy transition
are you excited by this project because
the big argument around green hydrogen
is that it's really expensive
yes I think uh if we look back in the
days of Renewables of solar and when
they were all very expensive back then
but because there are push from the
government push from companies they have
been decreased their costs and we
believe the same thing will happen for
green hydrogen in the Futures so that
means it will get cheaper and but app
for every new technologies this will
start out expensive and we need to put a
lot of efforts into it in order to start
reducing the cost to be used in the
future as well personally I'm very
excited about this project that is
happening in Egypt it is actually among
a lot of other projects that has been
announced over the past few months
leading up to cop 27 we have companies
own around the world looking to invest
into each to make green hydrogen and for
anyone that doesn't know of course green
hydrogen is hydrogen made from renewable
energy
okay thank you very much interesting to
your thoughts uh Ming coily thank you so
much for joining us
now you can get to all the latest news
from cop27 on our live blog so just make
sure you scan the QR code on the screen
right now and uh just before we go a
reminder that our weekly climate Show
with Tom Heap it's back and you can
watch it on Saturdays and Sundays at 3
30 in the afternoon or at 7 30 in the
evening
and of course we'd love more questions
actually from you you can scan the QR
code here or you can go to any of our
social media accounts and put your
questions in the comments and Tom will
answer some of your questions in his
show
that's all from us today join us
tomorrow for the very latest from cop27
and the rest of the news affecting the
planets